[Musik]
die Bundesregierung berät über das liebe
Geld für 2023 die Ampel lobt die
geplanten Entlastung da sitzt kein
großes Wunder die Opposition bezeichnet
sich gegen als Mogelpackung viel los
hier im politischen Berlin und damit
herzlich Willkommen zu viertel nach acht
meine Gäste heute Abend sind FDP
Bundestagsabgeordneter Olaf in der Beck
der für die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht stimmte Jugendforscher
Professor Bernhard heinzemeier mit
erschreckenden Zahlen ein Drittel
unserer Jugend hat keine Hoffnung mehr
publizistischen und Lehrerin Verena
brunsweiger sagt Kinder machen nicht
glücklicher Kinder schädigen das Klima
Publizist Georg afrohr der die Zukunft
für Deutschland sehr sehr düster sieht
und mein Name ist Lena schick und ich
möchte heute abend an die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
erinnern es ist meine
Herzensangelegenheit weil ich finde wir
diskutieren darüber viel zu wenig in den
Medien lassen Sie uns dafür einmal ein
Gedankenspiel machen stellen Sie sich
vor dass sie nach jahrelanger
kräftezähne Ausbildung in etlichen
Berufsjahren plötzlich nicht mehr
arbeiten dürfen sie schauen hektisch in
die Medien wie jetzt der Verstand ist
wie lange dürfen sie im Beruf noch
ausüben so ergeht es in Deutschland
nicht nur den Pflegern die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht sieht
seit Mitte März vor dass alle
Beschäftigten etwa in Krankenhäusern
Pflegeheim und Arztpraxen eine doppelte
Impfung gegen kobit 19 vorweisen müssen
das gilt auch für Medizinstudenten wo
sich sehr viel an uns gewandt haben ab 1
oktober wird die Regelung auf drei
Impfungen verschärft legt ein
Mitarbeiter dem Gesundheitsamt kein
entsprechenden Nachweis vor kann ein
Betretungsverbot verhängt werden das ist
ehrlich gesagt nichts anderes als ein
Arbeitsverbot die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht ist meiner Meinung nach
nicht solidarisch sondern asozial und
muss weg ich habe hier ein Politiker am
Tisch der hat dafür gestimmt und mich
interessieren jetzt erstmal die
Beweggründe für die Entscheidung damals
die Beweggründe waren eigentlich sehr
einfach wir hatten eine Zeit in dem wir
eine Delta Variante hatten die durch
Deutschland wütete und ich hatte mich in
dem Moment klar von Abwicklung
entschieden wohl eine rabelgruppen zu
schützen und da war für mich klar dass
ich zu dem Zeitpunkt
auch genauso abgestimmt habe wenn wir
heute an omeleton denken dann ist das
eine andere Geschichte eine andere
Verlauf der Corona des Coronavirus heute
würde ich das nicht mehr tun wenn der
Virus genauso wäre wie er jetzt ist also
das war für mich eine Entscheidung als
Abgeordneter wo ich gesagt habe mein
Gewissen hat mich einfach geleitet und
gesagt jawohl ich muss wohl rabelgruppen
einfach schützen den Krankenhäusern und
deswegen habe ich diese Entscheidung
getroffen voll aus vollen Bewusstsein
aber ich war ja auch die einzige nein
sie haben ja auch gegen die allgemeine
Impfpflicht sich positioniert das ist ja
der Unterschied bei ihnen gegen
allgemeine für einrichtungsbezogene
warum sie haben selber gesagt der Virus
ist jetzt ein anderer um jetzt mal nicht
in die Vergangenheit zu blicken warum
ändert die Politik das jetzt nicht die
Politik ändert es ja wir werden das IfSG
jetzt in diesem Monat noch anpassen wir
sind auch in einer Koalition da muss man
gucken was möglich ist gar keine Frage
und ich glaube auch da haben die Freien
Demokraten schon dazu beigetragen dass
wir sehr viel
verantwortungsvoller mit dieser ganzen
Situation umgehen können ich glaube wir
handeln da auch sehr
verantwortungsvoller als Freie
Demokraten
wie lange wird es die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht noch
geben
der Koalition gibt es keine Gespräche
darüber die allgemeine also die
einrichtungsbezone eben nicht zu
verlängern und dass du auch schon mal
eine gute Nachricht Frau wie sehen Sie
das sollte es überhaupt noch bis Ende
Dezember gibt es da nicht irgendeine
schnelle Entscheidung seitens der
Politik dass man das jetzt aufhebt also
ich bin natürlich für diese Vorträge
Aufhebung der mir bis heute niemand
sagen konnte wie wir so vielen
corona-maßnahmen vielleicht hat es auch
nur gemacht worden mit Herr Lauterbach
noch mal eine Nacht ruhig durchschlafen
kann ohne Panikanfall ich weiß nicht ob
es solche therapeutischen Maßnahmen in
der Koalition auch besprochen werden
denn nur so kann ich mir das erklären
wenn du bis heute konnte mir die Frage
nicht beantwortet werden also ich
generell gegen gesetzliche Maßnahmen
dieser Art da die Freiheit des Einzelnen
für mich über nahezu allem anderen steht
Punkt 1 Punkt 2 die meisten Menschen die
sich dem entzogen haben oder die in der
Presse aufgetreten sind auch aus meinem
Bekanntenkreis sind selbst Ärzte oder
Pflege oder Pfleger oder Schwestern
niemand hat bisher die Frage wirklich
beantworten können warum ausgerechnet
eine Berufsgruppe die mit der Krankheit
unmittelbar konfrontiert wurde im Alltag
nicht einfach nicht berücksichtigt wurde
sondern wir sind zum Teil eben entlassen
worden und dann klagt man über dem
Pflegenotstand das stimmt doch irgendwas
nicht ja und mir hat eine Ärztin gesagt
den Namen darf ich will ich nicht sagen
weil heutzutage ist es gefährlich seine
Meinung zu sagen in Deutschland aber die
Frau die also hier dürfen Sie Ihre
Meinung
die die Noten verteilen aber es ist ja
so dass zum Beispiel Impfschäden die
aufgetreten sind nach Impfung verdeckt
worden manipuliert worden und Ärzte die
niemand haben bestraft worden abgemahnt
wurden nur soviel dazu also insofern
halte ich das für eine repressive
Maßnahme weil wir Druck ausgeübt und
nicht eine aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
angemessen klare Antwort die wollten sie
haben haben sie bekommen sehr klare
Antwort wir geben mal
weiter wie stehen Sie dazu ja also ich
für mich ist kein besonders großes
Problem weil ich denke mal das muss kein
Pfleger ich bin kein Pfleger nicht aber
die Motivation ist ja wirklich und diese
lauter besonders vulnerable Gruppen zu
schützen und man braucht in einer Klinik
keinen keinen corona-hotspot also denke
ich mir dass die Überlegung durchaus
nachvollziehbar war und ja für mich gibt
es Bereiche in der Gesellschaft da
müssen sich die Leute eben diesen
Regelungen unterwerfen um andere ich für
die einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht bin
ich ich bin gegen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht aber warum sind sie für die
einrichtungsbezogene da ja auch geimpfte
geimpfte anstecken können also es ist ja
nicht so dass wenn jemand geimpft ist er
die vulnerable Patienten nicht mehr
anstecken kann da sich die Wissenschaft
ja eindeutig einig ja aber es ist doch
so und das sehen wir auch dass Leute die
geimpft sind der geringere eine
geringere Wahrscheinlichkeit haben die
Krankheit zu bekommen und das ist sicher
das auch schon
Wahrscheinlichkeit es ist der mehrere
Verlauf vor dem geschützt wird im
übrigen auch nicht bewiesen dass vor dem
schweren Verlauf
geschützt werden
ungeimpfte Pflegekraft gefährlicher für
den Patienten ist als eine man kann
durch dadurch dass man dort geimpfte
Leute hat das Geschehen ein bisschen
besser kontrollieren entschuldigen Sie
ich habe mal eine Frage an Sie können
Sie mir eine Klinik nennen in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland die zurzeit
ein corona-hotspot ist
nur zur Zeit ist sie keine es gibt ja
auch gerade gesagt
bitte bleiben Sie doch logisch eine
Diskussionsführung
ich habe heute noch mal nachgeschaut
dann muss ich ihn benennen können nicht
vielleicht morgen sollte wöllte könnte
na ich habe gesagt man hat ihn
verhindern
die Kraft zuzuhören und das zuzunehmen
und zwar inwiefern die Kranken
corona-hotspots sind und aktuell sind 3%
der Intensivbetten mit corona-patienten
belegt ist kann aber auch sein dass sie
was anderes haben und Test haben der
positiv ist
richtig feststellen
aber die Zahl drei Prozent ist ja sehr
sehr sehr gering selbst wenn man die hat
wahre Münzen nimmt die ganze
corona-geschichte seine von hinten bis
vorne ich bin kein Corona Leugner bin
auch keine sogenannter Querdenker aber
ich bin glaube ich ein gut Denker und
kann sein
Querdenker ist ja heute sind sie Nazi
nein äh es ist ganz einfach so dass in
dem Augenblick wo jemand eingeliefert
wird ist ich kenne selbst Leute die auf
gestorben sind am Herzversagen und dann
wurde Corona auf den Totenschein und
wieder zugeschrieben das ist hier
passiert immer in der Klinik das könnte
ich Ihnen belegen ich glaube gar nichts
mehr
Frau brunsberger sie sind ja
maskengegnerin wenn man das so sagen
kann das steht im Netz nein das kann man
so nicht okay
genau
weiße unterwegs angeklagt weil sie
angeblich ich habe alles gewonnen die
Beleidigungsklage ist vom Tisch und ich
musste auf meine Anwalt aber einmal noch
mal beschreiben das kann ich schon
machen also ich habe eine
Grunderkrankung und deswegen ein Masken
Attest bin also befreit es gibt so
gewisse Kräfte die das nicht so gerne
sehen die nicht akzeptieren können dass
es noch andere Krankheiten außer Corona
gibt unglaublich hat man sowas schon mal
gehört aber okay gut es wird alles getan
Menschen wie mich zu schikanieren zu
diskriminieren zu diffamieren aus rechts
hinzustellen als sonst was hinzustellen
ich habe dienstlich sogar Probleme
bekommen ich finde dass das allerletzte
und unfassbar impertinent und insolvent
also unüberwindbar was haben sie für
Probleme
da darf ich mich leider nicht äußern ich
habe auch allgemein nicht die
Möglichkeit mich hier so aus dem Fenster
zu lehnen wie ihr alle beneidenswerter
weil das könnt weil ich als bayerische
Beamtin des mäßigungsgebot habe die
vergangenheitspflicht und so weiter ich
darf leider nicht fast nichts tun mir
sind die Hände gebunden ich habe einen
Maulkorb
ich finde es sehr schade gerade nach
manchen Sachen die ich hier schon gehört
habe aber vielleicht ist diese Aussage
auch Aussage genug ich mal und wie
gesagt natürlich habe ich gewonnen weil
ich den Polizisten nicht beleidigt habe
das hat er sich nur ausgedacht weil er
ja linke Feministinnen sowieso nicht
leiden kann und denen kann man schon mal
eins mitgeben wenn sie es gerade
anbietet na das hat er geschafft daher
das finde ich super herzliche Grüße an
dieser Stelle ich könnte mich jetzt noch
darüber aufregen wie man vielleicht
merkt und auch zu Recht merkt vielleicht
ich versuche das mäßigungsgebot zu
beachten in jeder Hinsicht aber ich fand
halt schon wirklich persönlich sehr
verletzend wenn man einen chronisch
kranken Menschen schikaniert und
diskriminiert und als asozial hinstellt
also das geht für mich einfach nicht und
wie gesagt
ich verstehe
Ärger von bestimmten Menschen natürlich
weil sie könnten auch kein Recht machen
als Staat also Sie können sich allen
immer alles Recht machen muss erstmal
der erste Punkt der andere Punkt ist sie
sagen es gibt Regeln um frische
garnieren ich sage andersrum es muss
Regeln geben um auch Menschen zu
schützen vor einer Krankheit also wie
gesagt wir sind nie also ich bin auch
nie unterwegs gewesen dass ich gesagt
habe ich glaube da nicht dran dass das
keine schweren Verläufe geben kann oder
wie auch immer ich glaube auch daran
dass ich wenn ich geimpft bin
selbstverständlich geschützter bin vor
einem schweren Verlauf also gar keine
Frage und alleine davon dafür würde es
sich für aus meiner Sicht lohnen sich
impfen zu lassen ich weiß nicht ich habe
in meinem wenn ich mit dem Deutschen
Bundestag irgendwohin fliegen muss da
kriege ich zig Impfungen da frage ich
auch nicht was ist das für Impfstoff etc
pp der wird mir einfach gespritzt und
fertig weil sonst komme ich da gar nicht
rein in dieses Land also
ich gehe nicht gleich darüber Körper um
das ist einfach der Punkt wenn in
bestimmten Ländern die ich einreisen
will gesagt wird du musst der
Gelbfieberimpfung haben dann habe ich
eine gelb eine Gelbfieberimpfung
mitzubringen und nachzuweisen und möchte
nicht habe da bin ich einfallen die
etwas provokantes ich gebe es direkt
schon mal zu gibt es die Maßnahme sie
sind ja nicht nur Politiker sie sind ja
auch Bürger gibt es eine Maßnahme wo sie
heute sagen also die kann ich auch nicht
mehr verstehen die macht mich auch
wahnsinnig ja also ganz einfach also
beispielsweise die maskenpflicht im
Flugzeug oder eben
der Bahn bleibt wie hat die Koalition
aufgehoben
einfach eine Einigung gefunden hat und
Koalition und das das was ich daran
persönlich nicht verstehe wenn ich da
gesichert FDP-Politiker sondern als
Bürger muss ich sagen natürlich ärgert
mich wenn ich im ICE immer zu nach Hause
fahre nach der Sitzungswoche dass ich
dort Maske tragen muss weil ich das denn
nicht verstehe warum darf ich das da und
da nicht und ja aber es ist halt auch
ein Punkt wo ich sage auch eine
Koalition ringt sich zu Entscheidungen
durch die sozusagen uns die Freiheit
Stück für Stück wieder zurückgeben und
wir wollen Sie an diesem Schritt nicht
hindern und wenn man dann die Krücke
findet über das europäische
Gleichheitsgebot zu sagen in allen
Fliegern ist die abgeschafft und die
kriege ich dann einfach abgeschafft dann
freue ich mich darüber und dann machen
wir das sehen Sie das ist der Grund
warum ich froh bin dass sie in der
Koalition sind FDP sie dürfen das nicht
mehr sagen
ja Gleichschaltung Nummer ist doch ganz
klar dass sie sich viel froh dass die
feinen Demokraten da sind ärger mich oft
über die besonders wenn
gesellschaftspolitischen Fragen an
bestimmten Teilen aber zumindestens
haben sie in der Corona Sache gestanden
bevor
jetzt hier in Helga vor und dann wie
gewohnt ja also ich bin der Meinung dass
die Politik nicht den Mut hat den
Menschen die Wahrheit zu sagen über die
Situation in Deutschland
das immer wieder nur versucht wird mit
Placebo und mit tupferchen die Dinge zu
übertünchen und an die warmen Ursachen
der Probleme unserer Gesellschaft nicht
herangegangen wird hier beglauben alles
mit Geld lösen zu können das können wir
aber nicht wir können uns weiter
verschulden wir können weiter die
Leistungsträger belasten was ja der Fall
ist was wir aber nicht machen wir weisen
die Bevölkerung nicht darauf hin welche
wirklichen großen Probleme dieses Land
hat die eine grundlegenden Reform an
Kopf und hauptbedürfen ich nenne als
eines Beispiel die Überalterung unserer
Gesellschaft es sind in diesem Jahr
werden wir marschieren wir auf 114
milliardenzuschuss an die Rentenkasse es
ist dies wird bis zum Jahr
2028 auf 130 Milliarden ansteigen was
heißt denn das bei weiter rückgehenden
jetzt gibt einen kleinen gegenschwenk
Geburtenraten das heißt der
Generationenvertrag ist ganz einfach
nicht mehr funktional das heißt hier
muss nachgebessert werden wir haben eine
enorm verdeckte kriminalitätsquote im
Bereich der Gewaltkriminalität das wird
schön geredet weggeschminkt in den
Statistiken die Ursachen werden nicht
klar benannt jeder weiß sie aber keiner
traute sich zu sagen ich auch nicht
mittlerweile so jetzt müssen sie sich
schon sagen ganz starke
Gewaltkriminalität im Bereich bestimmter
ausländischer mitbürgergruppen das ist
einfach Tatsache das können Sie in jedem
Holz herbericht nachlesen in Paris zum
Beispiel da hat man das ist sie jetzt
veröffentlicht in 55% aller festen Namen
am Tag Personen die eben nicht wie soll
ich das sagen Bio Franzosen sind die
flüchtlingskrise Schuld nicht die
flüchtlingskrise es gibt Flüchtlinge und
Flüchtlinge es gibt deutsche kriminelle
es gibt diesen Jesus ich stelle aber
fester sind bestimmten
Bevölkerungsgruppen auffällige
Gewaltphänomene auftreten die in anderen
Bevölkerungsgruppen nicht in dieser
Massierung auftreten ich glaube das kann
mir niemand abstreit in der Lage ist
auch eine betriebsstatistiken zu lesen
ja das ist einfach ein Fakt darüber wird
herum geredet wir sind mittlerweile
Digitalisierung in Europa auf Platz 13
abgerutscht vom Platz 9 auf platz 13 von
100 Universitäten dieser Welt besten
sind wir auf Platz 99 mit der einen
einzigen deutschen Universität München
die Politik des die Verhältnisse hier im
Land wir definieren alles über den
Erhalt des Wohlstands und das ist viel
zu kurz zu griffen ich muss Ihnen sagen
die beste Idee die ich in den letzten
Jahren gehört habe ist das Pflichtjahr
dass man einem Menschen sagt du hast
doch meine Gemeinschaft eine Pflicht zu
erbringen nicht nur zu Forderer und zu
nehmen das ist ihre persönliche
meinungstragendes und wenn das nicht
erkannt wenn das nicht erkannt ist
wieder was ich würde sagen Rentner vor
beim sozialen Pflicht ja aber wir haben
genug geärgert schon ja und meine Eltern
auch ich brauche keine Belehrung
überarbeitet
in Lübeck wie sehen Sie das denn wenn
Sie das Hören also die Politik ist
bezogen
ich muss da immer sagen ich muss da
immer sagen wenn wir da mal einen Strich
ziehen und sagen wo hat eigentlich diese
neue Ampel übernommen und da muss man
wirklich sagen da muss ich ein recht
geben die Digitalisierung sind wir im
Standard das ist so
was machen wir sozialen Systeme die sind
sozusagen
nein das mag alles richtig sein
hat kaum mehr Munition gehabt um sich
überhaupt gegen irgendwas aufzustellen
und da muss ich sagen da ist diese Ampel
als Sie gestartet ist nicht nur mit
Krisen gestartet also wir sind ja
praktisch noch nicht einen Tag ohne
Krise regiert dann haben wir auch mal so
sagen und trotzdem versuchen wir das
eine zu tun nämlich Sicherheit zu
schaffen für unsere Bundeswehr für
unsere Verteidigung für unsere
Versorgungssicherheit etc pp und auf der
anderen Seite aber das andere zu tun ein
neues ein neues Start zu streichen ja
natürlich schaffen sie auf dem Weg also
wir sind doch wirklich auf dem Weg also
das muss man vielleicht auch mal positiv
sind und sagen wir sind auf dem Weg die
Versorgungskrise ich rede jetzt erstmal
nicht von der Preiskrise komme ich
gleich zu weil
Versorgungskrise die Versorgungskrise
werden wir in den Griff kriegen ich bin
mir da ganz ganz sicher ich bin ja nur
selber Vorsitzender meiner Fraktion im
im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
und beschäftige mich damit jeden Tag und
ich glaube wirklich dass wir schaffen
werden auch durch diesen Winter zu
kommen und wir werden uns aber auch mal
aufhören das Problem sein sondern der
nächste Winter ist die Zeitung lesen ne
also in der einsatzung steht so eine
andere steht so also ich glaube mit noch
mehr LNG Stationen die wir jetzt
sozusagen installieren wo wir Gas
anlanden können werden natürlich die
Probleme auch kleiner werden sie sich in
Sicherheit wenn Sie das jetzt hier hören
wenn sie sich als Bürgerin sicher ich
hoffe die Zeit ich habe dieses mäßiges
Gebot deswegen kann ich hier nicht zu
teilen nämlich gerne möchte aber hier
musste ich mich wirklich zusammenreißen
meiner Themen man kann da nicht zu ihnen
rassistisch anmutenden Parolen
gewisse formuliert mitbringen
naja aber ich wollte schon noch darauf
sprechen kommen nein nein
also wir verstehen uns die tatsache ist
aber dass sie durchaus recht haben was
zum Beispiel toxische Männlichkeit bei
Pariser bonlive bewohnen
Männlichkeit ich bin kein
intellektueller könnten Sie mir erklären
weil wir haben tatsächlich ich weiß
schon dann ist man gleich islamophob
wenn man sowas sagt aber sie haben
gesagt hier darf man sich äußern
Gebot erlaubt wir haben ja
beispielsweise junge Muslime die sich
dann radikalisieren in so bestimmten
Moscheen etc ich bin nicht islamophob
nur um es nochmal klar zu stellen aber
trotzdem fällt mir ein Gewaltpotenzial
auf ich lese auf französische Bücher im
Original ständig und kenne mich dann aus
die Presse verfolge ich dort auch also
das ist schon klar das sagt ja noch
macron wir haben da ein gewisses Problem
mit zum Beispiel Arbeitslosen
muslimischen Jugendlichen nicht nur in
der politikelle in Deutschland ganz
genau und da muss man halt dann auch
ansetzen mit einer ich weiß nicht
welches sich hier bei jungen Arbeit
irgendjemand macht doch auch sehr gut
Forscher also man kann da schon mit
einer vernünftigen jungen Arbeiten mal
ansetzen und dann die Leute auch
Schulen wissen Sie ich habe in Berlin
über zwei Jahre in einer Wohngegend
gewohnt in einem Haus mit über 200
Muslimen und zwar in Berlin-Neukölln
sowie vielen meiner Diskutanten oft
voraus der nun den Zucker Bezirken
wohnen und da kann ich Ihnen sagen dass
ein ganz verfestigtes hartes Männerbild
antisemitisch bis in die Knochen
auf Krieg und Gewalt eingestimmt und es
wird in Elternhäusern gestürzt in dem
Kneipen hängen Erdogan Bilder und andere
Dinge also wir was dagegen
verstreut wird die Realitäten sind
einfach anders
ein Lösungsvorschlag was würden Sie sich
von der Politik wünschen wie soll die
Politik vorgehen dass sie sich sicher in
Deutschland Straftaten begeht aus dem
Status heraus der Duldung oder ist immer
wieder verlängerten Aufenthaltsrechts
muss sofort abgeschoben werden
Straftäter sollen prinzipiell ihre
Strafen im Ausland in ihrem
Herkunftsland verbringen also zum
Beispiel in Uganda oder ruand
eine Weile gesessen hat wir können nicht
unsere Rechtssystem auf Menschen
übertragen die kein rechtskonsens mit
unseren Werten haben das kollidiert sie
können ein Rechtssystem nur so lange
erhalten solange eine Mehrheit sich mit
seinen Grundfesten in Übereinstimmung
befindet in Frankreich beginnt 7,4
Prozent der Bevölkerung 19,8% aller
Straftaten entschuldigen Sie das ein
Missverhältnis das hat ja macron eine
Woche bekannt gegeben
Abschiebung bei Straffälligkeit bei
nichtwilligkeit hier sich an die Regeln
zu halten das ist der Weg sonst werden
sie die rechte weiter größer machen was
ich furchtbar fand sie mal wie sieht die
Jugend darauf als Jugendforscher machen
sie auch viele Umfragen wie blickt die
Jugend auf die aktuelle Lage in
Deutschland
[Musik]
und vor allem stimme ich mit der
Stimmung nicht überein es ist ja wieder
so ganz typisch wir leben in einer Zeit
wo jeder ein Opfer ist und sich in
seiner Opferrolle inszeniert man darf
nichts mehr sagen man wird sofort lassen
Sie mich vielleicht auch kurz mal reden
ihren Alarmismus verbreiten
wahrscheinlich persönlich das zweite ist
ist ja ihr Alarmismus nicht meine ich
habe keine Freunde
Emotionen die können sie sich behalten
essen sie selber
dieser Alarmismus und da sieht man auch
hier ja stört jedes vernünftige Gespräch
also wir können uns hier nicht mehr
vernünftig austauschen wirklich nur mehr
Emotionen im Spiegel ist Zynismus Ironie
es sind ohnehin alle Idioten und die
ganze Politik nur voll Trotteln
Politik ist an allen Schuld also man
kennt ja kennt ja diese diese diese
diese wirklich diese diese Argumentation
und ich meine ich wünsche einen Land wie
Deutschland ich lebe das seit 22 Jahren
und bin bin sehr glücklich keine ärgeren
Probleme als dass man sich gegen eine
pandemische Krankheit impfen lassen muss
und dass man im Flugzeug eine Maske
trägt also ich habe jetzt im Flugzeug
eine Maske getragen ich habe das ich
habe das überlebt nicht aber aber
es gibt auch sehr viele Menschen sie
sind nicht eingeschränkt fühlen und
nicht jedes mal so ein Gezeter aufführen
also es gibt es es gibt es gibt zum
Beispiel ich finde es sehr vernünftig
für mich im Flugzeug eine Maske zu
tragen wenn man sich dort wenn man dort
sehr eng aneinander sitzt
in Ordnung aber es ist es mich zum
Beispiel Regen andere Dinge auf zum
Beispiel regen mich Dinge auf dass man
hier zum dass man immer davon redet weil
wir leben über unsere Verhältnisse wir
müssen lernen zu verzichten wissen sie
das untere Drittel der deutschen
Gesellschaft ja das lebt nicht über die
Verhältnisse sondern das hat einen Dreck
ja und die haben momentan andere
Probleme die haben Probleme ihre ihre
mietet und und auch auch die
Jugendlichen haben andere Probleme die
haben Probleme die die Leute haben dort
Probleme den den Kindern ihre
Schulunterlagen zu finanzieren die haben
Probleme ihre Mieten zu bezahlen ja aber
nur über den Verhältnissen leben naja
das hört man ja permanent also
schon egal mit welchen Alarm müssen ich
rede ob das einer von den Grünen ist
oder eher ein AFD nahe ist oder sonst
was ist ja es ist ja immer das gleiche
es sind es sind grobe
Verallgemeinerungen und man hat
irgendwie keinen Blick mehr für die
Differenzen in dieser Gesellschaft wir
haben wir haben die die corona-pandemie
hat das obere Drittel das wissen wir aus
unseren Daten sehr gut überstanden ja
das untere Drittel ja ist noch ärmer
geworden als es vorher war dass wir wir
mit in Deutschland
bestimmt bestens wissen was die
psychologischen Folgen für die
Jugendlichen ich weiß das ich weiß das
bestens es ist ich kann sie dann auch
kurz erklären wenn man Jugendliche und
Kinder nicht in die Schule gehen lassen
lässt dann schneidet man sie von ihrer
gleichaltrigen Gruppe ab wir sprechen
heute von der sogenannten selbst soziale
Sozialisation in der Gesellschaft die
jungen Leute unterstützen sich
gegenseitig beim Erwachsen werden wenn
ich ihnen den Zugang ja zu dieser
Gleichaltrigen Gruppe abschneide dann
produziere ich sozialisationsdefizite
mit dieser
situationsdefiziten kämpfen wir heute
wir haben Kinder die in der nicht nur
ihre psychologischen entwickeln sondern
auch in dannentwicklung ein halbes bis
ein Jahr zurück sind also wirklich da
irgendwer mit sich da irgendwer nur ein
wenig so aufregen würde ja wie wegen
einer Maske im Flugzeug ja dann wäre ich
schon zufrieden dann würde ich die
Masken Aufregung auch noch gleich Abzug
akzeptieren da könnte ich Ihnen jetzt
noch ich habe die Zeit ich zehn andere
Dinge auch noch sagen worüber man sich
aufzunehmen überhaupt nicht mir geht's
einfach darum dass wir eine permanente
aufregungs eine Kultur der permanenten
Aufregung haben
über gewichtet ich möchte nur dass wir
über andere Dinge auch ähnlich engagiert
diskutieren zum Beispiel über die Armen
und in unserer Gesellschaft dass man
über die über Kinder die heute aber wie
gesagt na das ist das was ich einmal das
was diese alte Geschichte wir wird bei
uns darf keiner mehr sagen und wir sind
alle unterdrückt das sage ich gar nicht
mehr
wir machen jetzt einmal eine Statistik
reinschauen dann wissen Sie alle wenn
sie reinschauen
aber Sie können ja nur adressieren
etikettieren aber nicht argumentieren
können
Sie denken wenn sie nämlich jetzt das
Thema hören
mich die ganze Zeit darüber dass die
Debattenkultur die wir in unserer
Demokratie haben also wirklich verfällt
und dass wir wirklich nur noch in
Schwarz und Weiß denken dass wir
wirklich nicht mehr aneinander zuhören
können miteinander zuhören können dass
wir auch nicht mehr miteinander reden
können und ich finde dass das auch viele
viele Probleme wie Panikmache Alarmismus
etc einfach fördert und da müssen wir
einfach gegen arbeiten und wenn ich sehe
auch wie also ich arbeite ja nun in
einer Koalition das sind drei
unterschiedliche Partner und wenn wir
immer nur aufeinander eindreschen würden
und einprügeln würden wir nicht ein
einziges Gesetz machen wir würden Dich
ein einziges Gesetz für das Land
gestalten können und ich glaube wir
müssen einfach wieder lernen miteinander
zu reden miteinander auch zu streiten
den Streit auch anzuerkennen um daraus
wirklich gute Schüsse zu ziehen und ich
rede nicht von dem Kompromiss auf der
kleinsten Ebene ich rede von dem
Kompromiss der uns weiterbringt und ich
glaube da sollten wir uns irgendwie
versuchen auf einen guten Weg zu bringen
dass wir auch dort im medienschulung
gerade bei jungen Menschen etc sie ran
führen dass man wieder miteinander redet
und streitet und nicht jeder gleich
stigmatisiert wird die Menschen
demonstrieren gehen in diesem Land es
jeder darf in diesem Land demonstrieren
weil er hat ja eine Meinung und die ist
doch völlig klar es geht ja nicht um
uniformismus es geht ja darum jeder der
eine Meinung hat kann dafür natürlich
auch gerade stellen kann für
demonstrieren gehen überhaupt kein
Problem dafür sind wir eine freie
Demokratie aber ich warne davor zu sagen
die Leute die demonstrieren gehen sind
grundsätzlich alle schuldig oder die
entsprechend grundsätzlich meiner
Meinung und deswegen muss ich sie
verteufeln also da war nicht wirklich
vor das heißt sie finden die Proteste
auch völlig in Ordnung sind nicht gegen
Protest in Deutschland also die müssen
natürlich also ich hoffe dass es auch
Proteste sind die von dir sozusagen auch
begründet sind ich glaube einfach dass
viele Menschen einfach auch gar nicht
mehr die Komplexität dieser
Zusammenhänge einfach verstehen können
wie wir es nicht sagen dass die die
demonstrieren dass dich alles verstehen
weil sie nicht schlau genug sind oder
wie auch immer das wird damit gar nicht
sagen einfach nur damit sagen dass wir
durch auch
Zeit ja ein Beispiel ein Beispiel
beispielsweise ist wir glauben
eigentlich nur das was wir glauben
wollen das merke ich mir sehr viel
Menschen ich lese immer nur das was ich
lesen will und dann lese ich da immer
weiter
Spiel ein Thema wo sie sagen okay das
wird eigentlich nicht komplex genug
gesehen naja also sagen wir mal wenn wir
uns über das IfSG beispielsweise
unterhalten das Infektionsschutzgesetz
unsere Corona und wenn wir da einfach
hergehen und sagen
was also wenn ich erlebe was bei mir in
meinem Büro passiert ist beim
Mitarbeitern wenn sie sagen sie sind für
oder gegen corona-maßnahmen dann kriegen
sie mittlerweile von jeder Seite
tausende von Menschen
und die die rufen Sie an die Dinge in
die Leitung teilweise lahm ich kenne das
von meinen Twitter-Account die können
sie gar nicht mehr nachlesen ich
antwortet auch nicht mehr drauf weil das
sind übelste Beleidigungen etc was
verliert jede Koordination
in diesem Land wir haben kein Problem
mit der Meinungsfreiheit wir haben
einfach verlernt unsere Meinung zu sagen
und zwar auf ordentliche Art und Weise
und darüber zu diskutieren ich finde das
lohnt sich dafür zu kämpfen dass du
wieder eine Streitkultur in diesem Land
kriegen weil das so eine Sendung wie
heute das beste Beispiel wir können ja
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein aber wir
müssen es einfach lernen das akzeptieren
und nicht den anderen gleichen Schublade
zu stecken und sagen also weil sie jetzt
eine andere Meinung haben als ich will
Meinungsklima denn auch mal anders in
diesem Land also nehmen sie in den
letzten Jahrzehnten eine Veränderung war
ja ich nehme meine deutliche Veränderung
war ich wollte nur was sagen zu
Meinungsklima ich glaube die Diskussion
zwischen uns beiden in meinem Nachbarn
und mir hat gezeigt wie es in diesem
Land läuft der hat nicht kein einziges
Sachargument gebracht bis auf eines das
falsch war er hat in zwei Drittel seiner
Ausführung etikettiert und mich
attackiert und mit Adjektiven belegt
aufgeregt kämpferisch Krawallmacher das
ist alles das übliche und am Ende ich
hatte darauf gewartet hatte mir AFD nee
artistenbildung gemacht haben AFD nahe
stehend bitte bitte konzentrieren sie ja
wieder Verhaltensweise
die Leute interessiert mich machen
jetzt er hat es nicht
die typisch linke Argumentation
der deutschen lebt unterhalb oder ist
arm das stimmt einfach nicht dieses rein
gelogen es sind 15% der Deutschen die in
prekären unteren Drittel der Geschenke
der Bevölkerung ist ein Drittel so eine
Menschen im Deutsch kann ich auch noch
also im unteren dritte ist ein Drittel
und davor ich bin keine so gute
Mediatorin ich würde sagen wir bleiben
beim Zimmer
Therapeuten also jetzt machen sie drauf
ne ja also
insofern ist das der Herr direkt von der
FDP das hier ist ein Paradebeispiel das
vergifteten Kultur ich möchte nur ein
Sachargument beitreten beitragen 2019
hat alles noch eine Studie über das
renommiertes Institut zwei Drittel der
Deutschen haben heute Bedenken ihre
Meinung zu sagen 50% war das bitte
entschuldigen Sie bitte im August 19
erschienen es ist den letzten Tagen
jetzt erst der neue Untersuchung
gekommen die deutschen das gleiche wird
da bestätigt dass ihnen gesagt uns die
Shell Stuhl da muss er sich besser
auskennen sein Metier Jugendstudie das
heißt es gibt einen bestimmten Bereich
von Themen wo man lieber das sagt es sei
gesagt wird und das ist kein
demokratisches Gesellschaft das ist der
Beginn der unterdrückergesellschaft wenn
ich heute höre dass in
Nordrhein-Westfalen benutzen
aktionstelefone eingerichtet werden wo
man Leute melden kann die in einer
anderen Meinung zu bestimmten Dingen
haben
aus meiner Sicht absolut unmöglich wir
haben ein Beispiel Frau
braunschweigergruppen verzerrt der
Lebenszahl 100 Prozent über dem der 70
eine andere Meinung haben du musst sehr
eigene Minderheit ist auch meine Meinung
sagen ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob sie
in Sicherheit sind
Debatte heute sie sagen ja ganz
plastisch sie fühlen sich in ihrer
Meinung unterdrückt weil sie nicht alles
sagen dürfen
ich kann jetzt nicht mein diensthand
wieder mal attackieren das kommt nicht
so gut an aber ich habe tatsächlich ja
erlebt man darf nicht frei äußern was
man so denkt ich mache das gerne hier
das ist mein aktuelles Programm
amerikanischen arbeitgebersdorf reden es
geht nämlich eigentlich darum um das
dienstliche gehts hier gar nicht so es
geht ja um ein Thema dass ich seit drei
Jahren sehr prominent vertritt und auch
als einzige in Deutschland was bisschen
traurig ist und eigentlich viel sagt
über unser Land da ich nämlich aus der
März dieses Buch im amerikanischen als
allgemein im Anker amerikanischen
Bereich vertrete und dort die Reaktionen
180 Grad anders sind und mir begeisterte
jeden hausflotten und ich denke mir
Hoppler wieso sind wir in Deutschland
eigentlich mal wieder
in eine richtige Unterbrechung danach
sind wir wieder für Sie da bis gleich
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen weiter mit
der These von Frau brunschweiger die was
mit Kindern zu tun hat
ja ich probiere propagiere ja seit
ungefähr drei Jahren landaufland auf das
kinderfrei Leben das fängt unter anderem
mit meiner lieblingskraneffekt zusammen
kann man auch googeln ist eine
kanadische schwedische Studie und die
besagt dass 58,6 Tonnen CO2 eingespart
werden können wenn ich mich persönlich
beispielsweise nicht reproduziere hier
haben wir die anderen kleinen
Punkte wie weniger fliegen weniger
Fleisch essen das ist halt alles
verschwindend gering im Vergleich und
tatsächlich hat dieses Studie dazu
geführt dass ich mich dann vor paar
Jahren entschieden habe nein ich werde
keine Mutter das war aber nicht der
einzige Grundsatz sondern natürlich als
radikal Feministin kann ich euch nicht
den patriarchalen Imperativ befolgen
wenn Sie möchten kann ich Ihnen das
erklären sie können dann auch Fragen
nachdem sie beitragsgeschehenlichkeit
auch schon verschwindend
ist natürlich gerade wir hatten ja schon
die ganze Zeit die Pandemie und so
weiter und ich frage es geht schon
corona-babys ach wie süß ich denke mir
ach wie irrsinnig muss ich wirklich so
sagen weil was für eine Welt ist das
würde ich ein Kind ich bin so froh dass
ich mich so entschieden habe vor paar
Jahren ich bin jetzt 42 okay ich habe
regelmäßige Blutungen alles gut also ich
werde jetzt die letzte Phase der
fruchtbaren Zeit auch hoffentlich auch
noch hinter mich bringen ja das ist so
ein bisschen
so gesagt sie finden ja eigentlich
Frauen die jetzt ein Kind bekommen ihr
Sinne wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden
habe natürlich ja weil jetzt gerade in
der Zeit kann man durch den Kind nicht
zumuten dass es diese ganzen
Schulschließungen überhaupt keine
normale Jugend und Kindheit mehr haben
ja ich muss die unterbrechen weil den
Krieg und diese Klimakatastrophe aber
ich finde es dann also nicht so gut sich
jetzt zu reproduzieren schwanger ja
genau ja
spannend hier am Tisch weil sie haben
mir damit eigentlich gesagt das ist aber
gar nicht aber das heißt ich finde es
ganz spannend wirklich
ganz viel gewöhnt wenn ich sage dass ich
schwanger bin ganz viel sagen aber ich
bin noch nie gewöhnt also noch keiner
hat gesagt
nein deswegen frage ich mich wie das bei
Ihnen als Lehrerin das ist überhaupt
kein Problem ich freue mich dass Sie
heute Abend hier sind ich habe sie
besonders gerne übrigens weil ich
schwanger bin zu dem Thema heute
eingefallen weil ich so furchtbar
spannend finde um jetzt nämlich mal zu
fragen wie wie nehmen das denn die
Eltern ihrer Schüler auf also sind ja
auch Lehrerin ich würde mich jetzt
wundern wenn mein Kind später also jetzt
wird's ja noch nicht so bald zur Schule
gehen aber wenn es dann zur Schule geht
und sagt ja die Frau brunschweiger Mama
die hatten heute erzählt ich soll später
lieber keine Kinder kriegen fürs Klima
also das mache ich ja natürlich nicht im
Unterricht da muss ich present perfect
und was ich heute im Lehrplan so vor
finde also ich meine da komme ich
logischerweise nicht mit meinem privaten
Zeug hier das ist ja klar das
Publizistin und Autorinnen und radikal
für Münzen haben andere Agenda als jetzt
das was ich hier im bayerischen Lehrplan
zu machen ich habe kein Haustier auch
wegen dem Klima
und genau also ich möchte heute auch die
Lebenden in der Wildnis zu Hause sein
den Tiere wie zum Beispiel Giraffen
Elefanten und so weiter wir sind ja im
nächsten Massensterben und Arten sterben
und ich möchte nicht dass noch mehr
Tiere wegen uns Menschen Aussterben in
meinen wir sind so viele Milliarden und
es heißt dann immer so schön
Habitatverlust na gut das heißt gut
deutsch das hat die Menschen mal wieder
was zu betonieren den Tieren wegnehmen
und ganze Tierarten aussterben ich finde
aber diesen anthropozentrismus sorry
nicht so gut ich finde den im Gegenteil
sogar Grund falsch und ich kann es nicht
mehr in meinem Gewissen vereinbaren wie
man noch mehr Konsumenten für den
Kapitalismus hier als wir persönliche
ausploppen zu lassen
geworden das wissen wir ja gar nicht man
weiß es rauskommt wenn sie das denn
nachvollziehen die Argumentation von
Frau buhnschweiger nein ich muss erstmal
einer gewissen Fassungslosigkeit aus
okay denn ich habe noch nie einen
Menschen getroffen der so traurig aus
wie sie und so an der Welt verzweifelt
ist nicht beleidigt werden das ist nicht
wenn ich trauer und wenn ich Traurigkeit
feststelle ist dass eine Feststellung
meinerseits die ich dann wohl vielleicht
vermute ich habe überhaupt nicht nein
sehr fröhlich und zwar weil ich keine
Mutter bin in Ordnung nein darum geht es
gar nicht die Mutter sind nicht das ist
letztendlich ihre Entscheidung aber es
geht mir darum dass sie praktisch eine
Absage an das Menschsein formulieren
doch natürlich wenn Sie dafür plädieren
dass keine Kinder mehr auf die Welt
kommt oder weniger das bewegen was heißt
denn das schon wieder das ist in weniger
was ist denn mehr überlegt denn das Fest
ja ich kann sagen das ist hörig was sie
machen entweder zynisch ignorant das
glaube ich aber bei ihnen nicht sondern
es ist eine besondere Form ich kann sie
nicht nachvollziehen von Egozentrik sie
können sie können doch von sich aus
nicht festlegen sie verneinen das Mensch
sein die menschliche Entwicklung sie
verneinen verneinen das andere Kind
Menschen Kinder kriegen sollen an denen
sie vielleicht Freude haben haben sie
sich mal vorgestellt wenn eine
Gesellschaft aussieht die sich zu dem
entschließt was mit denen wird wenn nur
noch alte Knochen rumkriechen wie ich
und ja verstehen sie da lacht da wird er
sich freuen wenn er endlich verreckt das
mache ich nicht aber
ein wenig mäßigungen so nein nein
Sklave benimmt ist zurecht ein Sklave
sie hat ihrer Stelle wenn sie aufrecht
werden möchten sie längst im Beamten
Status verlassen aber ist ein anderes
Opfer sind nein ich finde ihre Haltung
unglaublich und macht mich sehr traurig
und mir fällt dann noch was anderes ein
es kann nur deutschen Frau schon mal in
der deutschen Gesellschaft schon mal
Persönlichkeiten der Name mich nicht
nennen möchte die ihren Kinder sich
versagt haben weil die Zukunft nichts
bringe solchen wirklich apokalyptischen
und auch menschenfeindlichen Positionen
kann ich mich nicht einmal weiter
aufzuhören
einmal alle Meinungen ab wir wollen ja
miteinander debattieren nicht nur
Monolog gegen Monolog als Jugendforscher
vor allem wenn sie darauf auch blicken
auf die Jugend wie sehen Sie denn die
These von Frau Bohn Schweiger also ich
kann es ich möchte da jetzt nicht gegen
diese theseargumentieren ich kann nur
sagen ich persönlich habe ein
corona-kind bekommen das ist jetzt
zweieinhalb Jahre alt und macht mir
wahnsinnig glücklich und wie ich jetzt
fortgeflogen bin hat sie sich an meinen
Fuß geklammert und das war rührend noch
eine zehnjährige Tochter sie ich glaube
das Problem ist dass wir dass da
wirklich für mich ein Bild
ausschließlich rational argumentiert
wird weil da geht es ja auch um Gefühle
und Emotionen und ein Kind zu bekommen
da gebe ich schon recht diesmal immer
vernünftig über eins bekommen da weiß 60
ist nicht unbedingt vernünftig aber es
ist macht mich glücklich und es ist
macht mein Leben schöner und und und ich
glaube das Kind ist auch sehr glücklich
alles ist gut soziologisch betrachtet
ist es so dass wir sehen
dass das Bedürfnis nach Familie immer
größer wird vor allem bei jungen
Menschen und auch wieder nach Kindern
also das heißt man hat den Traum eine
wirklich eine funktionierende Familie zu
haben Kinder in die Welt zu setzen auf
möglichst aufs Land zu ziehen und dort
glücklich und und friedlich zu leben und
und ich finde es irgendwie ist in
verwundert mich auch nicht weil die
sagen uns ja auch diese Welt ist so
herausfordernd und so schwierig geworden
und es ist so viel Wettbewerb und so
viel Krisen ja ich möchte einen Raum
haben wo ich mich zurückziehen kann und
einfach glücklich sein kann und ein
bisschen in Harmonie leben kann und ich
glaube das ist das wichtige das heißt
wenn du die Familie so nüchtern
betrachte dann wird man einfach dem dem
den diesen diesen dieser Kultur dieser
Familienkultur und das ist dieser
emotionalen Kultur nicht gerecht wie
sehen sie es ja sagen ihre Meinung dazu
also
ich habe drei Kinder und ich bin auch
total glücklich seit Juli Ende Juli zum
18.7 habe ich meine erste enkelt
Fahrzeuge kriegt das total super und ich
kann ihnen auch berichten meine Tochter
ist wirklich fröhlich und glücklich also
deswegen finde ich das etwas irrational
also ich kann das nicht so richtig ja
ich kann das nicht so richtig
nachvollziehen ich glaube ich musste ja
absolut und ich muss auch sagen ich
arbeite lieber dafür wenn ich gegen den
Klimawandel arbeiten will aber ich
lieber dafür im Parlament und schaffe
Regeln und Rahmen dass wir ein besseres
Klima sozusagen in den Griff bekommen
und geh nicht zu solchen irrationalen
Momenten über und entscheide mich dafür
keine Studien die Frau Braunschweiger
Recht geben die sagen nicht wegen dem
klimano sondern die sagen kinderlos ist
mein glücklicher und auch Publizistinnen
die sagen Kinder sind ein
freiheitskiller also ich glaube nicht
dass man da glücklicher sein kann frau
glaube ich einfach nicht weil Kinder
geben einem so viel und Kinder man kann
von Kindern auch wieder lernen und das
ist eben genau das was hier völlig aus
der Acht gelassen wird und insofern
finde ich das gut ne dass sie
dass ich die Nachwuchs in diesem Land am
Laufen halte wird bestimmt politisch
streitbar was er hier immer mitbekommen
will und den nächsten Monaten aber Frau
Braunschweiger wenn wir jetzt darauf
blicken und sie die anderen Meinungen
emotional emotionales Thema
typischen deutschen es tut mir leid als
Männer Meinungen und die typischen
Klischees ich kann schon Bullshit denken
ich könnte trotzdem wenn ich Botschaft
die Sie vielleicht wissen wenn ich sage
ich könnte Bullshit schon Bingo spielen
wenn ich höre wieder menschenfeindlich
oh mag keine Kinder ist nicht
zukunftsorientiert ne das ist genaue
Gegenteil ist ja schließlich der Fall
und ich zum Beispiel merke ich euch
immer diesen tiefen Narzissmus bei
Eltern es muss mein Kind sein und meine
schönen blauen Augen muss ich verehren
weil jemand adoptieren wir haben 3000
Kinder zum Beispiel im Waisenhaus in der
Schweiz
gewesen die können bleiben wo der
pfefferweg 2 für die interessiert sich
keiner nein ich muss unbedingt da dieses
minimi wie sehr im Anker amerikanischen
warum haben Sie nicht adoptiert wenn ihr
die Frage nicht zu persönlich ist
natürlich dienstlich viele Kinder und
Kinder von Freunden Verwandten ich habe
schon es müssen nicht meine eigenen
Kinder sein so ein Narzisst und Egoist
bin ich halt nicht so es gibt auch
Studien die sagen man wird demütiger mit
Kindern und weniger egoistisch weil man
natürlich für die Kinder sich
zurücknimmt aber es geht ja immer noch
um einen selber weil ohne mich geht es
denn das klingt gar nicht also das ist
schon eine sehr narzisstische Sache die
euch in der Angela merkanischen Welt bei
dem Thema Jugend und Kinder aber kommen
jetzt zu der These von Ihnen Herr Heinze
weil wir haben sie heute sehr
strapaziert
meine These ist dass eben das dass wir
leider Gottes die sehr viele sehr
schlüssige Befunde haben dass ich dass
ich junge Menschen in unserer
Gesellschaft
überfordert fühlen und das viele
irgendwie auch diese diese Zuspitzungen
die sind der Gesellschaft permanent gibt
also eher skeptisch betrachten also vor
allem und das ist jetzt wieder das Thema
auch für den Politiker hier unter uns es
gibt da relativ große Distanzierung von
der von der Politik also das ist da muss
man den deutschen noch gratulieren
möchte ich aus Österreicher derzeit 22
Jahre schon da liegt da ist es nicht so
schlimm wie in Österreich also in
Deutschland haben wir immerhin 50
Prozent die zum Beispiel noch den den
Politik der etablierten Politik
Vertrauen in Österreich ist das nur mein
Drittel wir haben und und weil wir
zuerst diesen diese kurzes kurze
Geplänkel wegen den sozialen
Unterschichten gehabt haben was wir
sehen in unseren Studien das betrifft
auch vor allem die Jugend dass sich die
Jugend aus dem unteren
gesellschaftsdrittel ja aus der unteren
Hälfte der Gesellschaft immer mehr von
der Politik zurückziehen und das Angebot
nicht wahrnehmen an der Politik
teilzunehmen das ist die Wellen nicht
das heißt wir haben oben wir haben eine
eine Kultur wir gehen einer Kultur
entgegen wo die bildungsnahen und die
die
sozialprivilegierten ihre Politik wählen
und die unteren sich immer mehr davon
zurückziehen dass sie für höchst
problematisch problematisch halte weil
wir dann dann und das wird jetzt die
Frage der nächsten Zeit sein sehen
werden ob ob diese Leute noch still
halten werden wenn die Probleme die
jetzt auf Sie zukommen nicht und das ist
vor allem Inflation und teurer wenn die
drückend werden weil wenn die in ein
politisches System integriert werden und
wir werden und das Gefühl haben damit
gestalten zu können wäre das nicht zu
problematisch wenn sie aber neben dem
System stehen dann kann das kann das
durchaus zu vorübergehend anomischen
Zuständen führen und davor die Jugend
glaubt ja nicht mehr nicht mehr an die
Politik sondern auch der Journalismus
hat es sehr schwer bei der Jugend die
Medien auch da ist großer Einbruch in im
Vertrauen was wäre denn ihr
Lösungsansatz also Sie haben ja jetzt ja
mit der innerbeck einen FDP-Politiker
sitzen wo sehen Sie den Lösungsansatz
die Jugend zurück zu gewinnen der Jugend
Hoffnung zu geben dann muss ich Ihnen
recht geben das ist bei den Medien und
bei den Journalisten ist wirklich das
Problem das ist offensichtlich ist und
ich sage das jetzt immer so unheimlich
dabei das dem Fenster raus dass das
wirklich eine Veranstaltung von einer
sehr engen engen Bevölkerungsgruppe ist
und wenn man jetzt zu ihm gesagt sie
hören immer den Radiosender denn den den
Deutschlandfunk Deutschlandfunk und ich
fahre auch wenn ich Fragen nach acht
Stunden mit dem Auto fahre komme ich am
Ende an haben gesagt ich habe eine
gehirner eine Gehirnwäsche hinter mir
und ich glaube das ist die Problematik
das ganze System ist dieses ganze
Mediensystem ist zu abgehoben und und
repräsentiert die Interessen dieser
Leute da unten nicht mehr und da würde
ich mir wirklich schnell was überlegen
weil kannst durchaus zu Problemen und
Verwerfungen kommen Sie gerne den
Deutschlandfunk
selten weil ich komme gleich dazu
richtig Radio zu hören also ich lass
immer Presse lesen und wenn sie auf die
Presse die ich ausgewählt habe und das
ist auch teilweise das ist das ist dann
teilweise auch ein Problem und ich finde
auch in der Tat ist es so diese schnelle
Medienwelt diese wirklich enorm schnelle
Medienwelt wir können auch uns mal wir
können uns auch immer nur medienmäßig
auf eine Sache konzentrieren früher hat
man das immer als ich aufgewachsen bin
hatten wir immer drei vier Sachen die
nebeneinander diskutiert worden sind wir
können das immer nur noch mit einer
machen bei das alles so stört dann
müssen wir auch alles wissen da müssen
wir auch das letzte noch unter dem
letzten Stein vorholen und auch die
letzte Ausnahmesituation sozusagen
rauskitzeln und ich glaube dass
irritiert auch Jugendliche und
Jugendliche verstehen dann diese
einfachen Headlines die einfach auch
polarisierend sind zum Teil die
verstehen die denn die können sie nicht
so richtig vollziehen und nachgreifen
weil sie wissen ist komplex und ich will
eins sagen aus meiner Erfahrung als
Abgeordneter ich habe ja sehr viele
Besuchergruppen auch auch gerade
Schülergruppen wenn man so ein
Kontingent für 250 Schüler in den
Deutschen Bundestag zu holen mit denen
zu sprechen und so weiter und alle und
ich besuche auch sehr viel Schule in
meinem Wahlkreis und das sind immer die
schönsten Veranstaltung weil sie auf
einmal merken wie Jugendlichen sind gar
nicht um politisch aber sie haben
einfach keine Lust mehr auf diesen
Konsum den wir hier einfach an Medien
zum großen Teil haben und wenn ich mit
denen Rede dass er frischen Diskussion
und die sind auch unglaublich
wissbegierig und ich würde auf keinen
Fall sagen dass die Jugend nicht mehr so
politisch ist und ich habe gerade auch
aus einem Wagen ich komme aus dem
Ruhrgebiet da gibt's ja nun auch die ein
oder andere Problemschule und ich habe
auch eine Hauptschule bei mir mal gehabt
und das war eine der wunderbarsten
Gespräche die ich geführt habe mit
Jugendlichen auch teilweise mit
Migration
ja ja
ist es so schön wie hier gesagt wird die
Schulen die Lehrer wenn die schön da
sitzen die Klassen ich muss zum Beispiel
sagen ich lerne das geht jetzt an euch
für alle dann ziehen wenigstens an euch
drei geht es ich lerne allen Klassen ab
der fünften man lässt die Leute Ausreden
man unterbricht niemanden
aber okay gut vielleicht darf ich jetzt
mal ohne unterbrochen zu werden ich habe
in der Schule gelernt kurz und bündig
nicht zu lange Monologe ja kurz und
prägnant doch das sage ich auch bei
aufsetzen das stimmt schon und man kann
dann zum Punkt kommen was ich auch tue
andere vielleicht jetzt hier eher
weniger aber gut okay nur mal ein paar
Songs sie fühlen sich immer in die
Exkurse rein okay auf jeden Fall doch
ist es also ich liebe das auch mit den
Schülern zu diskutieren ich habe ja
deutsch englisch also insofern da bin
ich sowieso ständig am Diskutieren und
das macht mega viel Spaß natürlich und
die Schüler lassen sie auch Ausreden da
bin ich mir ganz sicher
ich möchte jetzt nicht ihre
beeindruckende journalistische Laufbahn
hier aufzählen sonst brauche ich auch
noch länger als die Sendung ist aber sie
als Experte zu bezeichnen ich glaube das
ist ein Journalismus nicht übertrieben
wie hat sich denn die Medienwelt
verändert Wir haben hier gerade gehört
es gab früher drei Themen jetzt nur noch
ein Thema wie nehmen sie es denn weil
sind die Medien schlechter geworden
stattfindet das heißt die Tendenz im
häppchenjournalismus es wird also in
kurzer Zeit werden un ständig
Informationen über hitzerweise über die
Menschen hereingegossen viele
Jugendliche und ich habe die orientiere
ausgebildet viele Jahre und konnte von
Jahr zu Jahr feststellen wie sich das
Niveau verschlechtert das Denken in
Kausalitäten lässt enorm nach auch die
Sprachfähigkeit das heißt also dieses
den Genuss der Sprache auszuschöpfen und
Sachverhalte umfassend darzustellen ist
nahezu mittlerweile auf ein rudimentären
stand zurückgefallen 20 Prozent aller
Grundschüler in der Bundesrepublik sind
nicht in der Lage
satt gewisse Satzstellungen zu bilden
Sätze mit dem kreativ mit zu und
enthaupten Nebensatz zu unterscheiden
das ist eine Katastrophe das ist eine
Rückentwicklung in Zeiten des
Mittelalters entschuldigen Sie das so
sage es gibt in Berlin mittlerweile
Kurse Telefonate zu lernen und frei zu
sprechen und nicht mehr nur tipp tipp
tipp zu machen sondern mal ein wirklich
Satz voll zu artikulieren und die
Gegenantwort abzuwachen das Problem ist
Journalismus
in erlebt ist ja vor entschuldigen Sie
ich kenne jeder Sitzung die ich Gott sei
Dank muss ich keiner mehr führen aber
dass die Leute sitzen und selbst da
nicht wirklich nicht und dauernd wird
unterbrochen die besteht nicht die
Fähigkeit mehr als 6 7 Sätze überhaupt
anzuhören die wollen Sie denn dann zu
einem abgewogenen Meinungsbild kommen
halte ich für ausgeschlossen es gibt
Schüler die gar nicht mehr in
klassisches Buch lesen von dem Klassiker
Egmond oder so nicht oder Fontane die
begeister die begreifen was semantisch
gar nicht mehr nämlich keine Vorwurf den
ich den Macher die sagen was soll der
Quatsch warum soll ich diese
Schlüsselsatz lesen das halte ich für
eine Katastrophe ich habe jetzt seit
drei Söhne und auch ein Enkel bereits
bin sehr glücklich mit meinen Kindern
davon abgesehen ich habe den jetzt ein
Buch gestellt von fernheim von Schirach
das heißt ich will keine Werbung machen
aber das heißt Zigaretten und Kaffee es
sind so kleine kleiner Aphorismen und
nicht länger als zwei Seiten und da habe
ich gesagt guckt euch das mal an was
Sprache vom Markt auf einer Seite mehr
als ein Gemälde mehr als 3 Stunden tat
also wieso zum kotzen aber verstehen Sie
was ich meine das ist wir vergessen die
Erziehung der Gefühle die Erziehung des
Umgangs mit Sprache und Informationen
werden ich finde sie sagen viele
richtige Sachen also es ist anders das
richtig war mit dem Gehalt
gewaltthaltigen migrantischen Milieus es
gibt einige das ist und das finde ich es
auch richtig also das Problem dass wir
jetzt haben ist Punkt 1 das Bild
erschlägt die Sprache also das haben wir
das logische Instrument der Sprache die
argumentiert die wird eigentlich durch
das Bild weggewischt und die Sprache
steht nicht beim Vordergrund dass das
Bilder ansehen und das zweite ist dass
diese nervöse Gesellschaft in den in der
wir leben dazu führt dass die jungen
Menschen die Fähigkeit so Aufmerksamkeit
verlieren also das heißt die patention
sie haben das angeführt dass das
Fachvokabular dafür dass ich wirklich
also mein Gott den Mann ohne
Eigenschaften zu lesen oder sowas
Schlusswort heute mit der Aufmerksamkeit
weil wir sind am Ende der Sendung
angekommen das war die letzte
Unterbrechung für heute wenn Sie mögen
dann schalten sie doch morgen abend
wieder ein natürlich auch wieder
spannende Gäste hier und spannende
Themen es war sehr heute abend tschüss
[Musik]